my name is Gavin Leatherwood I am here
at BuzzFeed today to read some thirst
tweets is this like the Oh Gavin
Leatherwood is hard to ask and I want to
suck his peepee
that's a great start is it not watching
Sabrina and it must be said Gavin Ludwig
can hex this whole what does that even
mean how does one hex a whole I don't
want to know okay so the Nicolas scratch
saying call me daddy has made me moister
than an oyster mr. gammon leather would
choke the life out of me then set me on
fire mom if you're watching this right
now just fast-forward this is not for
you parents put a sensitive on your kids
you through Gavin Leatherwood could
punch me in the face and keep my car and
I would be grateful for the experience
got a revaluation use air man you
shouldn't let anyone do that to you
here's my daily Gavin Leatherwood thirst
week he can slice me with his jawline
and I'd say thank you what's up with
everyone wanting the abuse everyone
wants to be ran over or cut by something
or punched in the face and keyed cars I
want to suck Gavin leather wood studs
my feet are probably the ugliest part
about me so joke's on you Syrena I would
like to have it known that Gavin lava
live deserves to be gently tucked into
bed every night with a kiss on the
forehead now that is just the sweetest
thing ever it was like the most PG
cutest thing I've just made my heart
warm in a sea of thirst tweets oh this
is a big one me after chaos season one I
don't know who this manipulative little
is but I sure don't trust him it's about
me me after chaos season two Nick
scratch is my mother boyfriend and I
will protect him at all costs all caps
good I'm just trying to work my way into
your heart and clearly mission success
you haven't Leatherwood spit in my
unholy mouth people write this do you
guys just found these you weren't like a
so I mean I heard that you know there's
just like people just this is your daily
reminder that I'm a hole forget another
would you got to be much more than just
that if you want in here get me much
more
we got another long one here Gavin
Leatherwood please
I don't know if I can read this one but
you gotta read this one that is far out
I don't care if you're a man or a woman
or straight or gay or a bird or a muppet
Abel we'd all nicholas scratch i don't
know how a table and i would do that I
get it I got I'm just making a mess here
by the way are you guys okay yeah
yearning which I'm pretty sure is not
your name Gavin Leatherwood is the most
stunning man on earth sorry I don't make
the rules
that's sweet my mom thinks the same
thing it's just their biased opinion
hers and yours
gavel other would don't block me but I
want to suck your dick thanks Raphael ah
sweet of you
Jameela Jamil is limp wrist Raja Mila -
Mila I know her wrist is tweeting me if
you want to beat up Abu see anytime soon
I'm pretty much Thursday's I liked the
use of busi said if you know the real
other words Graf says gavel other words
bulge though he can choke me anytime
it's just socks that's not real you're
stuffing come on TV in underwear wanna
be convincing choke me daddy I will not
do that I'll probably go to jail I knows
with a nice
Gavin Leatherwood plays a 16 year old on
Sabrina but he's 25 in real life and I
would let I would let him split me open
like a doctor like surgically like you
want me to cut an open peek inside of
you
Elle says Gavin leather would let me
swallow your babies I know what that
really means
yabba Leatherwood can get it and by it I
mean my busi sandwich says someone how
gay are you me I'm drawing Gavin other
words abs at 3:00 a.m. but I get it I do
it - not - that would be weird Gavin
Leatherwood acting as Nick being
possessed by the devil also owns this
Buzzi another book see that's three
bookies we have so hard especially with
his tongue split down the middle I am
feeling things that tongue was
disgusting but I hate to each their own
if that's your thing that's your thing
I'm not knocking any of it
we made it half of those shouldn't make
the cut some of them will thanks guys
for watching I'm Gavin Leatherwood from
chilling adventures of Sabrina go stream
it part threes out
this was thirst wheats this was weird
glad I did it
you
[Music]